- [Voiceover] This is
a stressful day because
it puts a lot of pressure
on a relationship
I'm still not sure I wanna be in.
- I'm very impressed with
myself that I got reservations.
- You cannot afford this place.
- But I'm gonna make
this year very special
so I can slack off in the future.
- Realizing you will never understand
how much money I actually
spent to get ready tonight.
- Oh, this menu is a lot more
expensive than I expected
and it doesn't include wine.
- There's a $40 thong riding
straight up my asshole.
- Transferring money from
my savings to my checking,
just in case you want some wine.
- Bullshit about wine.
- Perfect.
Calming my nerves 'cause I'm gonna
tell you that I love you
for the first time tonight,
just to make this a little more special.
- Hi guys.
I will be making eye
contact with both of you
as I go over I very, very
expensive prefix menu,
which only contains two options.
The reason we do that is we need
to flip as many tables as possible,
we need to make the most
money we can tonight.
I hate your love and I hate this holiday.
Thanks so much.
- Oh, needing a picture for social media
to make all my friends jealous.
- You wanna show the world our love.
This is good.
- Everyone here's having
sex tonight but me.
- Kelsey, I...
- Oh my god, tell me I'm pretty.
- Validation.
I was gonna say that I...
- I'm getting up to show the world
how excited I am that my
boyfriend just proposed to me!
- We are so happy!
(patrons clapping)
- [In unison] We are seeking attention,
we are seeking attention.
- I'm trying not to play
into every attribute
of my stereotypical gender role,
but these guys are making me feel
so fucking feminine right now.
- I feel so upstaged.
- Being a stereotype.
- We get it, you're happier than us.
- You know what Kelsey,
maybe this a good time.
(wine glass shattering)
- I love you.
- I'm cheating on you.
- I wanted to say it first.
- I'm just glad you said it back.